it is a one-stop shop for small
businesses the city of north las vegas
launching a new program to help small
businesses launch grow and ultimately
connect christian casares joining us in
studio with more on what this new
program now has to offer well brian the
city of north las vegas wants small
businesses to thrive they have created
this program to connect entrepreneurs
with the tools to succeed
city leaders unveiled a new initiative
to attract and grow small businesses in
north las vegas it's called small
business connector which promises to
launch and expand provide low-cost loans
to entrepreneurs and connect job seekers
with employers
as the city slowly comes out of the
pandemic they want to offer a helping
hand to those small businesses
struggling to survive we will help you
with startup we will help you to recruit
employers
because there's so much ins and outs in
starting a business anything that you
need to know about a business or asking
about a business
[Music]
access to capital
finding employees how do i even go about
getting a business license the nlv
connector will be the first in nevada to
have an employee business hub located
inside a city hall this is funded by the
american rescue plan act and is part of
the city's ongoing coveted response
efforts
well another great feature about the
program is that the city has partnered
with unlv's small business development
center they can provide you with free
expert advice on how to start and grow
your business christian casadas 8 news
now